speaking of supreme court nominees
i guess in this case of successful
supreme court nominees unlike
mayor garland who was an unsuccessful
supreme court nominee
justice thomas is the last tough guy
left in america the last guy
with really rock-ribbed moral vision
uh honorable mentions to alito here and
i suppose even gorsuch even though i
still haven't forgiven gorsuch for that
transgender decision
the supreme court was asked to hear a
case
the final case of the 2020 election
regarding
mail-in ballots in pennsylvania there
were lots of questions about mail-in
ballots in pennsylvania
because probably most importantly the
supreme court or i'm sorry the
constitution of pennsylvania
prohibits the use of these widespread
mail-in ballots that we saw in the 2020
election
the pennsylvania supreme court in a very
politically motivated decision just
chose to ignore that part of the
constitution
the u.s supreme court didn't want to
hear about it then there was this issue
of mail-in ballots coming in
after election day whether or not that
those can be
those can be counted supreme court
actually was sort of willing to weigh in
on that but now
they're not willing to hear the case
regarding the validity of these ballots
sadly you got all the libs voting not to
hear the case
you also have john roberts but i guess i
repeat myself
you also have amy barrett voted not to
hear this case
you also have brett kavanaugh voted not
to hear this case
we fought real hard to give brett
kavanaugh that seat we fought real hard
to send merrick garland into political
irrelevance at least for a few years
and they went squishy they went squishy
on what should be a very simple
answer now thomas alito and gorsuch
did think that the court should weigh in
on this matter
thomas most vigorously so thomas
in his descent said something very
important
and it's important for not just this
election
because the court generally speaking
they did say we don't think that these
votes would have changed the results of
the 2020 election
however they could have very serious
impact in the future
and so we need to we need to take a look
at them
thomas said something here that
i have been saying since the 2020
election
actually i have argued with many
conservatives on this point since the
2020 election
and thomas you know how much i hate to
say i told you so thomas
seems to be on my side of this question
thomas wrote and actually a little
footnote in the case he says
we are fortunate that many of the cases
we have seen alleged only
improper rule changes not fraud but that
observation provides only small comfort
an election free from strong evidence of
systemic fraud
is not alone sufficient for election
confidence also important is the
assurance that fraud will not go
undetected this line i i want you to
highlight this
i don't know how you're going to
highlight it in the air as you're
listening to this
in a podcast on the radio or on youtube
but but make note of this line
an election free from strong evidence of
systemic fraud is not alone
sufficient for election confidence when
some of my
friends on the right uh in the days
after the 2020 election
were demanding they said we need the
evidence we need the evidence we need
the evidence i
agreed with them i said yeah you know
the trump team obviously needs to make
the case in court and they're not going
to be able to make the case if they
don't have evidence
however this election looks pretty
crooked to me folks it seems
like there was a lot of irregularity
going on and what some of my friends
even on the right would say
is if you can't provide all of the
evidence
then we must conclude that the election
was totally fine and there were no
questions it was absolutely legit
and i said no that's not true you don't
get to in the weeks and months before
the election
change practically all the rules all of
the important rules surrounding election
integrity
you don't get to violate the state
constitution for goodness sakes in
pennsylvania
to give an advantage to democrats you
don't get to
extend election day into election month
thereby diminishing election integrity
and making it more vulnerable to fraud
you don't get to extend the counting of
the ballots you don't get to do all
these things
that cut at the heart of election
integrity and then tell me the burden is
entirely on me to prove that there was
some shenanigans going on
i'm seeing what you're doing you're
taking away all of the safeguards
therefore it is absolutely my right to
raise questions
i it is absolutely my right to not have
much confidence in this electoral
process that's what
thomas is saying right here justice
thomas
the man the the man left on the supreme
court
i like some of the other guys too
depending on the day especially elito
but thomas thomas is
one of the most clear-eyed conservatives
in the entire country
he's making exactly the same point and i
don't think that there is anything
illegitimate or wrong or shameful
about pointing out that when you get rid
of a lot of the election integrity
measures
people are going to lose some confidence
in the election i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the michael knowles show
to check out the full episode hit the
link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts